I've been dreaming of doing a trip
through South America for years...
We're here with world-famous actor,
Ewan McGregor.
but life got in the way.
And now I've decided to do the trip
with my best friend Charley Boorman.
You've got to look after
the relationships in your life,
and if you don't, you're just...
you're losing something
that's very important.
We'll ride 13,000 miles,
from the southern tip of Argentina...
all the way to Los Angeles.
150 miles every day,
it's... a long way to go.
And if that wasn't
enough of a challenge,
we wanted to see if we could
do it on electric motorcycles.
I think it's the future, electric.
You'll be the first people
to go this distance,
charging as you go.
Oh, my god,
it's so great, isn't it?
-Nope.
-Uh-oh.
The power's just gone.
Ah, this is us on
the road, Charley.
This is us on the way, man.
I'm gonna get
attacked by this dog.
We'll ride through the
brutal Patagonian winter...
Look at that snow.
It's amazing how cold it is.
...we're gonna climb to the extreme
heights of the Andes
and experience the real
risks of high altitude...
I can't breathe.
I'm definitely getting sick, Charley.
...before witnessing the endangered
jungles of Central America.
You think about all of the
things that might go wrong.
I think we're lost.
Is this a road?
Roads might be a little--
Wow, whoa, I'm falling off.
In the middle of the night,
things just go around
your brain, don't they?
I have real fear.
I don't want anyone to get hurt.
They just roll around.
I'm not gonna make it.
Towing somebody on
a bike is dangerous.
What if the bikes don't work?
What if we can't charge the bikes?
What if it snows tomorrow?
I really enjoy the
unknown of a town,
just coming across the
people we come across.
Buenos días.
Amazing, the people.
Learning about the cultures,
and seeing how people
keep their traditions alive,
puts you in touch with
yourself and the world in a way.
I'm an actor.
What films have you made?
Did anybody see...
Star Wars?
No.
Don't think so.
None of these kids have
seen anything I've done.
Long Way Up,
two guys lost
in South America.